Так наразі виглядає польсько-український кордон.
Величезні черги вантажівок через протести польських перевізників.
Українські далекобійники, які застрягли перед кордоном,
буквально "живуть" у черзі.
Два тижні, чотирнадцять днів.
Хліба нема, води нема, нічого немає.
Ми в заручниках. "Сомалійські пірати" взяли нас в заручники.
Воду беремо, он в людей до хати йдемо до криниці чи що, просимо в каністри.
А живемо в машині, а де?
Вантажі, ми ж відповідаємо за вантажі, куди ми їх подінемо.
Паливо привезіть, люди замерзають, ***!
Нас кинули напризволяще. Ми заручники урядової ситуації.
Що вам ще сказати? Якщо уряд не вирішує, хто має вирішити?
І в нас тут ніхто не вирішує.
Польські протестувальники вже два тижні не дають проїхати вантажному
транспорту, який прямує в Україну.
Заблоковані пункти пропуску "Краківець-Корчова", "Рава-Руська-Гребенне",
"Ягодин-Дорогуськ". Польські перевізники вимагають, аби їхні українські колеги
в'їжджали на територію ЄС лише за дозволами.
Протест пов'язаний із відновленням дозволів, які були скасовані
для України під час війни. Їх не скасували зовсім,
але їх скасували, щоб проходили гуманітарний і військовий транспорт,
і все, що пов’язано з війною, щоб можна було швидко доставляти.
Але, на жаль, Україна швидко скористалася цим
для звичайних комерційних вантажів.
Ми абсолютно не проти України чи українських компаній.
Це результат недбалості польського уряду в діалозі з Європейським Союзом.
Ніхто не запитав нас, далекобійників, як ці рішення вплинуть на нас,
нашу діяльність і транспортний ринок, як у Польщі, так і в ЄС.
До повномасштабного вторгнення Росії в Україну з кожною країною ЄС
були двосторонні договори про видачу певної кількості дозволів на перевезення,
про яку країна домовлялася на початку кожного року.
Такі угоди існували з Німеччиною, Польщею, Чехією та іншими країнами.
Після нападу Росії на Україну Євросоюз ухвалив рішення скасувати ці дозволи.
І вже у червні 2022 року Україна і ЄС підписали угоду
про вантажні перевезення автотранспортом.
Вона мала діяти рік, але у березні цього року ЄС продовжив її дію
до 30 червня 2024 року. Ідеться про перевезення з України
до країни ЄС і назад, або транзит в третю країну.
Через блокаду на кордоні з обох боків застрягли
понад 10 тисяч вантажівок. І поки що офіційні тристоронні
переговори не допомогли розв'язати проблему.
За словами заступника міністра, і Польща, і Україна звернулися до ЄС,
аби зібрався спільний комітет, який розглядає всі питання
щодо цієї угоди. Але це довготривалий процес.
І оскільки підстав для скасування угоди немає,
то "ЄС чітко артикулював, що не розглядає це питання".
Чому саме ці перевізники блокують кордон і яка взагалі ситуація
на польському ринку перевезень? Для Польщі це суттєва частка ВВП.
Близько 7 відсотків ВВП дають ці послуги.
Польща, коли входила до ЄС значно посилила свої позиції
на цьому ринку. Поляки після Німеччини - це другі за розміром
компанії на ринку автомобільних перевезень.
Тому для поляків дуже важливо не допустити того,
щоб їх з цієї позиції хтось зміг би посунути.
Тому вони будуть закривати свій ринок і будуть намагатися
себе убезпечити від конкуренції.
У мінінфраструктури стверджують, що глобальної конкуренції
українські перевізники на європейському ринку не створюють.
Україна конкурує тільки з тими перевізниками,
які хочуть їхати конкретно в Україну та з України,
тобто тими, які орієнтовані лише на український ринок.
Польща була містком між Західною Європою і Росією.
Втрата одного великого ринку і не змога компенсувати його
українським ринком змушує ту асоціацію, яка заблокувала
польський кордон, говорити про втрату роботи, втрату замовлень.
Але потрібно розуміти, що це втрата замовлень туди - на схід.
Тобто вони не можуть везти на схід і звинувачують в цьому Україну.
В них ринок пішов, вони хочуть тепер сюди - в Україну…
Так ви розумієте, нам не треба польські товари.
Давайте так: нам не треба польських товарів, в Польщу не треба українських.
Ми їдемо і транзитом веземо в Євросоюз.
Вам тільки за дороги платимо, дизпаливо купуємо. Це вам ще й дохід. Все.
Польський перевізник везе товар до Львова,
а далі, каже, я не повезу. На Запоріжжя везти не хоче,
на Херсон не хоче, на Харків не хоче.
Каже, чого ти не везеш? Каже: "Там ракета падає".
То він до Львова вивантажив, а ти під ракети вези сам.
То якщо ти вже взяв, ти - герой, то завези на Херсон, завези на Запоріжжя,
на Харків. То він туди не їде, бо там війна.
У Львові вивантажив і все, будь здоровий, лапки назад.
Я вже, каже, герой. І без черги назад.
Я хочу запитати, чого вони не блокують кордон до Білорусі?
Ці перевізники возили товари до Росії і до Білорусі.
Той кордон не блокують вони. А до України блокують.
Протести польських перевізників на українсько-польському кордоні
розпочалися 6 листопада. Увесь цей час українські перевізники
втрачають тисячі євро через те, що їхні авто стоять заблокованими на кордоні.
Віцепрезидент Асоціації міжнародних автомобільних
перевізників України Володимир Балін повідомив DW,
що якщо найближчим часом не буде розблокований кордон,
то рік перевізники закінчать з критичними збитками,
що може суттєво позначитися на галузі вантажних перевезень.
Блокування польсько-українського кордону стоїть дуже гостро
й для галузі продовольчого ритейлу - компанії зазнають
значних збитків, відзначають в громадській спілці
"Український фуд-ритейл альянс". З огляду на таку ситуацію
на полицях українських магазинів може забракнути певних категорій товарів,
у тому числі й українського виробництва.
Адже через заблокований кордон неможлива доставка
деяких складових, з яких виготовляється продукція,
або пакувальних матеріалів.
Та і ринок пального боляче
сприймає блокування кордону.
Ми повинні розуміти, що це - як снігова куля.
Проблеми наростають, ті вантажівки, які стоять в чергах,
вони витіснені з обороту і їх не можна залучити до інших маршрутів.
Вже говорять про те, що відчувається брак машин, брак водіїв
на інших ділянках кордону. Такі повідомлення лунають
з країн Балтії. Крім того, блокування одного, двох,
трьох пунктів пропуску збільшує кількість машин на всіх інших
пунктах пропуску. Є повідомлення з Угорщини,
що вони вже не справляються з потоком. Так само на інших пунктах.
Тобто всі ці проблеми наростають, на жаль, тому, думаю,
втрати будуть ще більшими.
Асоціація міжнародних автомобільних перевізників України
вже вивчає юридичні можливості притягнення до відповідальності
польських протестувальників та польські місцеві органи влади,
які дали дозвіл на протести на кордонах, що призвели
до колосальних збитків. За словами Володимира Баліна,
його асоціація звернулась до польських адвокатів,
які захищатимуть права українського бізнесу.